c'est la troisième spirale aromatiques
de france après metz et chambéry cette
innovation s'installe à bois d'arcy dans
la spirale a été inaugurée par les
incroyables comestibles un mouvement
citoyen et solidaire d'agriculture
urbaine participative d1 croate
comestibles reconnect les gens entre eux
et à la terre nourricière
le principe c'est que nos actions sont
totalement ouvertes elles sont ouvertes
à tous
chacun peut venir à aider à faire les
plantations l'entretien mais également
venir partager des récoltes et ce ne
sont pas forcément les mêmes personnes
qui ont planté entretenu et ceux qui
vont effectivement partagé des récoltes
reprendre contrôle de ce qu'on mange de
la façon dont ses produits
et qui dit prendre le contrôle de ce
qu'on mange signifie aussi prendre le
contrôle de notre santé bien sûr alors
que si son jardin solidaire existe en
france à bois d'arcy on retrouve un lieu
unique en coopération avec sanoflore
c'est une spirale d'aromatiques
entreprises est allemandes et plantes
aromatiques et médicinales
on aura l'année prochaine sur nos trois
spirale à peu près une quarantaine de de
plantation différentes et donc d'essence
de plantes différentes
le conseil municipal des jeunes un
groupe scouts et des enfants d'une école
élémentaire participent au projet mais
l'initiative est ouverte à tous quand on
voit l'état de la planète aujourd'hui je
pense que ce genre d'initiative faut que
ça se multiplie à l'infini
je pense que c'est important de se
rappeler qu'un légume ça pousse dans la
terre et pour moi c'est vraiment
important essayer d'encourager même les
jeunes pour comprendre qu'il faut que je
prenne les choses en main pour l'avenir
et que bah ça dépend de nous et on peut
faire de très belles choses ensemble
prochain objectif pour les incroyables
comestibles de bois d'arcy continuer son
développement à l'échelle locale et
pourquoi pas nourrir toute la ville
grâce à ces jardins participatifs